j'aurai ce que je peut engager 2 t et
animateur pour jouer au théâtre
bien sûr tous les soirs à la madeleine à
partir de la rentrée est ce que vous
êtes libre non je le fais tu dirais que
là tout de suite non sans appel à
propositions aux deux
les deux me disent s'ils veulent ou
s'ils veulent pas c'est normal je peux
tout vous dire après allez-y vous est
proposée à camille combal et enora
malagré joue au théâtre
je peux aussi te plaît maman non non
c'est long alors je vous le dis je ne
dirigerai d'enora enora c'est bon
camille combal
il fallait rentrer à quelle heure à la
maison cette affaire 23h à non alors non
seulement j'ai ma vie non mais ils
décideront du même nom mais c'est vrai
c'est pas mal c'est 2-2 après l'audition
à la direction de télévision en ligne
c'est énorme
alors il aura jaune il est efficace ou
non et non avec akon cassou
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est ça c'est fort boyard
[Musique]